i got nipples could you melt me [ __ ]
i got a debate question for you guys
today if you get in a fight
and you [ __ ] your nose up if you can see
my shit's going off to the right
get phase surgery or just leave it game
game buzz buzz
buzz buzz dude you don't [ __ ] with the
nose
you don't mess with the nose it changed
your look for the rest of your life you
look like [ __ ] val kilmer you've seen
valkyrie lately
it's tough dude it's tough your boys had
some
no surgeries you just gotta leave that
[ __ ] also no one wants your boys
who's my boy you see your boys i'm your
boy you had some
oh yeah two reconstructive nose surgery
you had two nose jobs
two not hollywood nose jobs
reconstructive nose jobs
matter of fact i've been taught i've
been talking about getting you a deal on
one really
yes oh that's just taking a little bit
off little girl just a little girth
you know what i'm saying i got that
thick header bruh you need a two-car
garage that you want me to breathe
around you
feel me here's what i'm saying dude if
your nose is broken dude
you know prey on it i think what about
what about a breathe right strip
look pretty cool yeah but you have to
almost get a really light rope to kind
of hold
it over against one ear to really you
know you'd have to almost uh
lock it into it the problem is when
dudes touch their face they all look
exactly the same
you've had two nose jobs dude not like
what he's going for though he's going
forward the looks knows it seems like
what he broke his nose would you get it
for broken nose
shattered nose how can you not relate to
this guy
why am i the one relating to him because
you got a [ __ ] up note
dude the guy has shitty tattoos you had
a bad nose
this could be you hey rewind it let me
see how bad his nose is it's not bad
no i didn't it didn't look like there's
an issue yo what's going on theo what's
going on bro
it's the septum zone i got a debate
question for you guys today
you get in a fight and you [ __ ] your
nose up
if you can see my shit's going off to
the right if if they surgery accept them
or just leave it
gang gang buzz buzz gang bro face
surgery
let me look up like this let me see
yours that left nostril
that left nostril to fit a grape in bro
i put a grape in it yeah i know yeah
small one
yeah nothing frozen huh
oh dude you're my nostril over here bro
dude you can put mail in there dawg when
you went like this was the number 10.
really yeah because one of them is
thinner and smaller this one's large
yeah well my nose isn't you know it
isn't even on center did you break it
huh no there's just like something
inside like there's like some bad scar
tissue inside that kind of pulls it from
the inside
um i don't know probably childhood
violence
you know i don't know but the man went
in there they tried to they cut they
tried to cut some of it out but some of
it stayed in there oh damn
so cause i remember for like two days my
nose was kind of was straight
and then it i guess just grew back or
whatever
and i was like holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
crazy
but this guy dude i think you're fine
bro i think first of all i don't think
you got a problem
yeah i don't think you need a shirt i
don't think you need a nose job i don't
think you need anything maybe getting
more you start
david's you got a [ __ ] you got a
tattoo what is that an owl a bird no
it's a snake
it's two snakes oh you got two stupid
snakes i was thinking the same thing
dude you're fine bro you're going to
heaven dude
so i would chill out man i'd pull over
and get some rest i think honestly
yeah you look pretty tired i'm super
white teeth
i'd get more tattoos and say [ __ ] the
nose here's
the nose dude dude yeah if you get
another tattoo nobody's then it fits
yes you know i think if you have a
broken nose and you keep it you gotta
have like six tattoos to offset it
that's why i have so many tattoos my
face looks like [ __ ] just reaction
distraction yeah distraction damn yeah
suddenly like holy [ __ ] who i've been
looking at for a while yeah
that's why i won't go smart and i'm like
oh cool meg ryan that's cool
what else do we got uh 62 percent of
people
went with never touch your face ever
[Music]